[Musique]
salut bon d'abord désolé mais je vais
commencer par l'habituel demande de
partage et d'abonnement j'ai oublié de
le faire la dernière fois et il faut pas
que je m'étonne que ma chaîne ne décolle
pas si je ne fais même pas le minimum
bon cette vidéo devrait être
relativement courte c'est que j'ai assez
peu d'idées sur le sujet que je veux
aborder j'ai des intuitions mais elles
ne sont pas bien établies j'ai pensé que
le fait de chercher elle voulait
partager pourrait m'aider à les
clarifier et aussi que peut-être cela
vous conduirait à repentir et à proposer
un nouvel éclairage je vais commencer
par l'anecdote qui a amorcé cette
réflexion une amie me racontait une
soirée techno où elle était quelques
jours plus tôt elle me confier son
admiration pour les DJ qui avait joué ce
soir là
alors qu'elle me faisait le portrait de
ses musiciens ses yeux brillaient
intensément et moi de mon côté je
sentais une petite gêne j'ai donc tenté
d'explorer cette gêne pour comprendre à
quoi elle renvoyait
[Musique]
la première option qui m'est venue est
toute bête je suis jaloux je voudrais
qu'elle m'admire moi plutôt que c'est ma
première hypothèse parce que c'est la
plus ordinaire mais voilà même si je ne
fais pas une confiance extrême au
pouvoir de l'introspection je dois
reconnaître qu'un examen un peu attentif
m'invite à écarter cette option
notamment pour des raisons personnelles
qu'il serait sans intérêt de développer
ici bien sûr je peux me tromper mais il
me semble assez certain que ce n'est en
tout cas pas la cause principale on
reviendra dessus à la fin mais pour
l'instant mettons là de côté
[Musique]
la seconde hypothèse explicative qui
m'est venue à l'esprit renvoie à l'idée
de rapport de force ce qui me gêne dans
le témoignage de mon ami c'est qu'elle
révèle une forme d'admiration vis-à-vis
de ses musiciens or l'admiration n'est
pas un sentiment anodin il n'est pas en
conséquence l'admiration génère presque
automatiquement une dissimétrie dans la
relation à la personne admirée une
espèce de déférence dans le cas où mon
ami serait par exemple conduite à
rencontrer un de ces DJ il me semble
crédible que l'interaction soit
immédiatement prise dans une logique de
domination
cette domination n'est pas forcément
violente ni même toujours explicite
notamment parce qu'elle opère via une
impression spécifique celle d'être
charmée par quelqu'un
mais prenons une seconde pour remarquer
une subtilité linguistique être charmé
c'est en fait être sous le charme de
quelqu'un sous le charme comme sous
l'emprise de son charme c'est à dire
dominer par une espèce de force
psychologique cela suppose donc une
forme d'inégalité entre les deux
individus une inégalité de valeur au
moins ici sur le plan spécifique de la
création musicale
mais je crois que ça déborde ce seul
cadre puisque ça peut se traduire en un
sentiment du type or j'ai de la chance
de pouvoir parler à ce musicien si
talentueux alors que sinon ça se
limiterait à j'ai de la chance de
pouvoir écouter en concert ce musicien
s'est talentueux
donc je ne crois pas qu'un tes
sentiments soient anodin c'est le point
de départ de nombreux abus on voit ça
régulièrement et la super chaîne
patchwork a même consacré une vidéo à ce
problème quand ça concerne les
youtubeurs
ces situations d'admiration me semblent
dangereuses même quand elle se limite à
un champ d'activité précis au moins pour
ses raisons là
attribuer une valeur à un individu en
vertu d'une capacité que nous pouvons
expliquer c'est je crois qu'on ferait un
ascendant à l'autre et c'est donc mettre
en place une relation de pouvoir
déséquilibrée
sûrement pas aussi explicite que celle
qui se joue par exemple dans la relation
patron employée mais l'admiration est un
insecte qui suppose malgré tout la
reconnaissance plus ou moins consciente
d'une supériorité et ainsi attribue à
l'admirer un pouvoir d'influence sur
l'admirant
pour la dire autrement on écoute un peu
plus attentivement quelqu'un qu'on
admire mais alors quand on part
admiration
je crois que pour pouvoir parler
d'admiration il faut réunir deux
conditions 1 admirer quelqu'un c'est
toujours reconnaître à cette personne
une capacité à faire quelque chose dont
nous ne sommes pas capables on admire
pas quelqu'un qui fait des choses dont
on est soi-même capable c'est tout bête
mais ça ne suffit pas je peux tout à
fait reconnaître que telle personne est
capable de choses dont je suis incapable
sans l'admirer pour autant alors quel
est le deuxième critère on pourrait dire
tout simplement il faut accorder de la
valeur à la capacité qu'on reconnaît à
l'autre mais c'est pas sûr que ce soit
suffisant
donnons des exemples anna est une grande
footballeuse Bernard est un trader
exceptionnel Carla est la meilleure
dentiste David est un mécanicien hors
pair ce qui est intéressant à noter avec
ces exemples c'est que l'image que j'ai
de leurs compétences varie je n'ai rien
à du foot bon j'ai joué plus
jeune mais aujourd'hui je m'entends pas
le popotin donc bon même si je reconnais
Kana est infiniment plus forte que mon
foot ça ne m'enthousiasme pas des masses
quant à Bernard bah je déteste la
finance je suis sûr que Bernard maîtrise
tout un tas de compétences et de
connaissances techniques qui m'échappe
complètement pour autant je trouve ça
nul et pour moi c'est caché sa vie et
d'ailleurs aussi celle des autres de se
consacrer à la finance logiquement ça
n'induit pas d'admiration
je sais me laver les dents mais c'est à
peu près tout pour ce qui est de mon
savoir dentaire donc oui le gap
technique entre moi et Carla est abyssal
par ailleurs je trouve une utilité
évidente au dentiste heureusement qu'il
y en a mais ce n'est pas pour autant que
je vais éprouver ce sentiment
particulier qui est l'admiration
enfin David l'expert en mécanique et
bien c'est un cas intéressant parce que
même si je conduis très rarement même si
je ne me suis jamais passionné pour les
voitures ou les motos je dois admettre
que j'aimerais bien m'y connaître en
mécanique je vais dire que si d'un coup
de baguette magique on m'offrait une
expertise en mécanique je ne serai pas
blasé je ne souhaiterais pas au plafond
non plus ça ne changerait pas ma vie
n'exagérons pas mais je serai
sincèrement content je me dirais cool je
comprends comment un moteur fonctionne
je suis capable de le réparer
malgré le charme et l'intérêt que
j'associe à la connaissance mécanique
cela n'implique pas pour autant de
l'admiration à proprement parler je peux
être envieux du savoir de David sans
l'admirer alors quand il y a-t-il
admiration et bien c'est le deuxième
point je dirais que le deuxième critère
fondateur de l'admiration plus flou à
définir c'est quand la qualité ou la
capacité que le reconnaît à l'autre
déteint sur l'idée que l'on se fait de
la personne en général
on pourrait dire que l'admiration
commence quand la compétence qu'on
reconnaît chez l'autre déborde le cadre
de son effectuation c'est à dire quand
on associe consciemment ou non certaines
caractéristiques personnelles à la
compétence en question quand il s'agit
plus seulement de reconnaître une
compétence du type Alice sait faire X
mais quand cette compétence reconnue
implique à nos yeux d'autres choses que
l'on valorise également pour le dire
autrement c'est quand on attribue à
cause de la compétence en question une
valeur à la personne dans son ensemble
Alice a réalisé un film merveilleux
alors c'est forcément quelqu'un
d'intéressant Bob est un scientifique
important alors c'est forcément
quelqu'un d'intelligent ce type
d'association plus ou moins consciente
n'apporte rien d'évident
revenons à mon ami et à cette DJ
pourquoi parler ici d'admiration et bien
parce qu'il s'agit de musique et au
contraire de la mécanique des
compétences en trading ou en chirurgie
dentaire la musique appartient à un
domaine l'art qui jouit d'un statut et
d'une rat particulière
l'art c'est ce truc un peu mystérieux et
un peu magique sans doute qu'on peut
faire l'histoire de cette imaginaire
liée à l'art et probablement qu'à un
moment clé et le romantisme le
romantisme allemand incarné par les
frères Schlegel Caroline Schelling
Novalis ou de terrain défendait une
conception de l'art comme absolu
pensez-leur comme absolu c'est à dire
également comme accès à une vérité
métaphysique cela transforme
nécessairement l'imaginaire autour de
l'artiste
plutôt qu'un simple artisan de
l'expérience esthétique l'artiste
devient une sorte de mystique de mage de
chaman
le romantisme français de lui aussi
beaucoup au romantisme Manon pour aller
vite voir très vite le romantisme est un
mouvement culturel qui met l'accent sur
la sensibilité et mettre l'accent sur la
sensibilité c'est mettre l'accent sur
l’intériorité sur le vécu subjectif bref
sur la personne à l'origine de l'oeuvre
rapidement l'artiste est celui qui jouit
d'une sensibilité particulière et cette
sensibilité est valorisée quand on la
comprend comme une forme d'accès à une
vérité
d'autant plus que c'est une vérité qui
échapperait à celles et ceux qui ne sont
pas aussi sensibles
un exemple qui incarne cette idée c'est
la lettre du voyant de Rimbaud en voici
un extrait bien connu et fort révélateur
je crois
je dis qu'il faut être voyant se faire
voyant le poète se fait voyant par un
nom immense et raisonné dérèglement de
tous les sens toutes les formes d'amour
de souffrance de folie ils cherchent
lui-même il épuisant lui tous les
poisons pendant garder que les
quintessences
ineffable torture où il a besoin de
toute la foi de toute la force
surhumaine où il devient entre tous le
grand malade le grand criminel le grand
maudit et le suprême savant car il
arrive à l'inconnu
puisqu'il a cultivé son âme déjà riche
plus qu'aucun il arrive à l'inconnu et
quand affolé il finirait par perdre
l'intelligence de ses visions il les a
vu
je crois que cela fait assez
explicitement un portrait du poète et
par extension de l'artiste comme une
figure héroïque une espèce d'aventurier
un surhomme accédant à des dimensions
supérieures de la réalité
l'oeuvre devient tout à la fois la trace
de cette expérience le témoignage de
cette vision d'un au-delà du monde
ordinaire et l'avant-gout pour le
lecteur et la lectrice de cette vérité
qui ne s'est dévoilé pleinement qu'à
l'artiste
cela a donc une autre implication si
l'artiste jouit d'une aura prestigieuse
à cause de ses visions cette aura
déteint sur celles et ceux qui sont
capables de recevoir l'oeuvre en ce sens
être ému par l'oeuvre d'un artiste
visionnaire c'est en quelque sorte ce
hicer à la hauteur de cette vision
géniale c'est sans faire le dépositaire
d'où l'on voit apparaître une espèce de
logique un peu étrange qui lit l'artiste
à son audience le spectateur reconnaît à
l'artiste une supériorité mais ce n'est
pas sans contrepartie dans la mesure où
cette grandeur accordée à l'artiste lui
revient sous une forme indirecte
si je sais apprécier l'oeuvre d'un génie
c'est que je suis moi-même pas si loin
d'être génial
je vois donc ici deux problèmes à la
fois distincts liés 1 cette tendance
spontanée a accordé une espèce de
supériorité sensible implicite à la
personne qu'on identifie comme cause de
l'oeuvre aimée et deux la relation de
dépendance que cela induit chez le
spectateur ou la spectatrice c'est que
pour m'approprier quelque chose de la
grandeur de l'oeuvre que j'aime je dois
passer par la reconnaissance de cette
supériorité chez son auteur pourquoi et
tout simplement comme on disait parce
que l'on a tendance à voir l'oeuvre
d'art comme le produit et l'extension
d'une vision dont seul un être supérieur
est capable rappelons-nous ce que disait
Dieu ce n'est pas parce que nous jugeons
qu'une chose est bonne que nous la
désirons c'est parce que nous la
désirons que nous la jugeons bonne
jamais plus vrai qu'avec l'art je suis
profondément ému par une oeuvre musicale
cinématographique littéraire peu importe
plutôt que de prendre l'émotion pour
elle-même comme une expérience qui se
suffit je lui attribue spontanément une
cause si une œuvre à ce point c'est
qu'il y a une raison c'est qu'elle doit
être objectivement de bonne qualité
c'est une œuvre réussie une œuvre
réussie c'est-à-dire bien exécutée
original et non cliché fine et non
caricatural belle et non laide
intelligente etc bref toute une série de
critères qu'on nécessite plus ou moins
consciemment à l'oeuvre quand on a cette
impression qu'une œuvre d'art est
réussie et une telle réussite n'est pas
un accident s'autorise-t-on à conclure
dans la foulée c'est forcément le
produit d'un esprit supérieur d'une
vision
dans notre monde la conception de
l'expérience esthétique dominante
suppose un spectateur et un spectatrice
d'une offre d'art comme des agents
passifs recevant le message de l’œuvre
contemplant sa réalité
l'esprit du spectateur se laisserait
guider par le contenu de l'oeuvre jamais
ne présentons le spectateur ou le
spectatrices comme étant l'auteur de sa
propre expérience de sa propre émotion
aussi voyons-nous l’œuvre comme un
relais de la vision de l'artiste comme
le véhicule du message ou de l'émotion
qu'il cherche à nous faire passer par
conséquent il nous semble que l'on doit
la beauté et l'intensité de notre
expérience à l'artiste à son vécu
intérieur à ce qui se passe en lui au
moment de la création de l'oeuvre cette
impression là me semble peu saine pour
les raisons qu'on imagine aisément on
est dépossédé de notre propre expérience
puisqu'on
identifie la cause chez un autre être
humain dans la foulée on se positionne
dans une relation d'infériorité et de
dépendance à la personne qui a selon
nous rendu notre expérience possible
une relation d'infériorité et de
dépendance notamment parce que c'est une
expérience plaisante on veut donc
revivre l'artiste devient cette personne
qui détient les moyens de nous faire
vivre un certain type d'expérience le
genre d'expérience que précisément on
recherche cette association dans notre
esprit n'est pas sans conséquence on
pourrait être tenté d'y voir une
explication potentielle de la manière
dont notre société tant à défendre des
artistes qui sont par ailleurs des
salopards mais j'aurais tendance à
penser que c'est plutôt une affaire de
statut social de pouvoir ce sont des
figures institutionnalisées les attaquer
eux revient donc à attaquer les
institutions qui les ont validées et
elle se défendent bien les institutions
elles ont de plus gros moyens que les
militants
peut-être que ça existe quand même à
plus petit échelle genre Eric qui défend
et pardonne les déclarations homophobes
de son musicien préféré parce qu'il aime
tellement sa musique que ça lui ferait
trop mal de reconnaître le problème et
donc d'y renoncer
[Musique]
la troisième hypothèse explicative est
directement liée à la précédente je
crois je pourrais appeler ça la ligne
nation au concept de personnes ce que je
veux dire ici c'est qu'on a tendance à
voir les personnes comme les auteurs des
actions
Bob est un DJ qui fait danser les foules
quand ces fans ne regardent mixées avec
admiration ce qu'il voit ses Bob et le
regard s'arrête là à l'incarnation
visible de ses capacités de DJ on ne
voit pas sa mère qui lui a appris à
jouer d'un instrument quand il était
petit on ne voit pas son prof au
conservatoire de quartier qui lui a fait
découvrir les percussions indiennes on
ne voit pas les politiques culturelles
qui ont permis via des financements à
certains concerts d'avoir lieu dans la
ville de Bob enrichissant ainsi sa
culture musicale on voit Bob et on se
dit quel talent
c'est peut-être encore pire avec le
cinéma c'est une industrie et il faut
énormément de monde pour faire un film
de la production à la post-production en
passant par la musique les décors mais
en glorifie surtout les acteurs et les
actrices même les réalisateurs
réalisatrices sont moins connus et je ne
parle pas des scénaristes qui sont
pourtant à l'origine de l'histoire qui
fait le film mais c'est vrai aussi en
science le prix Nobel récompense une
deux ou trois personnes quand c'est un
labo et donc toute une équipe qui a
rendu la découverte possible
et sans doute ne faut-il pas s’arrêter
là dans la déconstruction du mythe de
l'individu performant ce n'est pas
simplement un groupe d'individus qui
rend possible une découverte
scientifique c'est une histoire une
culture une société ce sont des
décisions politiques des financements ce
sont les travaux des scientifiques du
passé aucune découverte n'est le fruit
d'un individu ou d'un groupe restreint
d'individus aucune réussite n'est le
fait d'une personne
pour prendre une image peut-être plus
parlante imaginez qu'on est tous dans un
bateau type galère il y en a qui rame
d'autres qui font la bouffe etc et à la
pro du bateau il y a bill avec une
longue vue et tout d'un coup Bill voit
une île ce serait gonflé de dire que
c'est Bill qui a découvert l'île on l'a
découvert tous et toutes ensemble
j'ai l'impression que notre monde a
tendance à applaudir Bill à lui filer
les lauriers là-dessus l'admirer lui
donner une position sociale avantageuse
un statut qui lui donnera un ascendant
sur les autres
alors revenons à Bob le DJ si
l'expérience est plaisante quand Bob et
derrière les platines il en est que le
représentant en un sens il me semble
problématique de lui attribuer tout le
mérite et vous savez ce que je pense du
mérite en plus si vous ne savez pas vous
pouvez aller voir cette vidéo
[Musique]
la quatrième et dernière hypothèse est
la plus intéressante à mes yeux c'est
elle qui a déclenché l'envie d'écrire
cette vidéo et elle ressemble en creux
les hypothèses précédentes mais c'est
aussi la plus difficile à développer
précisément parce qu'elle se heurte à
tout un tas de préjugés je pourrais
l'appeler le culte de la performance on
pourrait aussi l'appeler le culte de la
compétence
pour le dire autrement c'est l'idée et
le sentiment selon lesquels il vaut
mieux savoir faire quelque chose c'est
le fait d'associer une valeur à une
compétence à une capacité cela fait sans
doute un écho indirect et la vidéo de
patchwork sur le capacitisme c'est à
dire cette tendance à exclure du champ
politique les personnes à qui il
manquerait une capacité considérée comme
essentielle de manière plus générale
c'est cette tendance qui consiste à
valoriser le savoir-faire la maîtrise
technique
sans doute que ça rejoint la
valorisation des connaissances en
général cette idée toute bête selon
laquelle savoir c'est mieux que ne pas
savoir pourquoi cette intuition
là on retrouve quelque chose de la
jalousie dont on parlait plus haut quand
j'étais plus jeune et que je me
retrouvais dans des fêtes au lycée il y
avait toujours des garçons qui savaient
danser le rock moi on ne m'avait jamais
appris je trouvais ça injuste pourquoi
le fait qu'on n'est pas appris quelque
chose suffit à me rendre moins
intéressant moins admirable à l'époque
je ne déconstruisais pas cette
valorisation des compétences mais je me
demandais quand même pourquoi il
semblait plus important aux yeux de mes
copines et copains de classe le savoir
danser faire du skate ou dessiner que
d'être quelqu'un d'honnête de gentils de
fiable sur qui on peut compter etc
à 15 ans je ne me sentais pas cool parce
que j'avais le sentiment que je ne
savais rien faire
aujourd'hui quand je regarde autour de
moi j'ai parfois l'impression que ça
ressemble encore beaucoup à mon
adolescence
on continue à survaloriser les
compétences davantage que les traits de
caractère une illustration de ce
problème c'est ce qu'on évoquait plutôt
à savoir la glorification d'artistes qui
était par ailleurs des
il y a ce fameux débat tout pourri qui
n'a aucun sens faut-il se soucier
l'homme de l'artiste cette question est
débile je suis désolé de le dire comme
ça
à une époque on s'est demandé s'il
fallait dissocier l'oeuvre de l'artiste
ce qui n'est pas pareil en gros on
commençait à promouvoir le fait de
recevoir une oeuvre et de l'interpréter
indépendamment de l'individu qui en
était l'auteur typiquement cela voulait
dire par exemple ne pas chercher dans la
biographie de l'écrivain ou de la
peintre des éléments qui viendraient
éclairer le sens de l'oeuvre ne pas
donner d'importance aux intentions de
l'artiste c'est une problématique de
philosophie de l'art et à la son sens
dans ce cadre-là c'est à dire une
question qui concerne la réception
l'analyse la critique d'oeuvre d'art
c'est devenu ce problème beaucoup moins
bien posé qui consiste à savoir s'il
faut séparer l'homme de l'artiste et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
j'imagine que ça veut dire si on répond
oui qu'on peut célébrer l'artiste tout
en condamnant l'homme mais comment quand
on file un César à l'artiste Polanski
c'est bien l'homme Polanski qu'il reçoit
et c'est son compte en banque qui
encaisse les entrées en salle j'avoue
que j'ai du mal à piger la logique là en
plus pourquoi l'art serait-il un cas à
part
là n'est pas une activité à part dans
l'ensemble des activités culturelles
humaines pourquoi ne se demande-t-on pas
s'il faut séparer le sportif de l'homme
tel footballeur a violé une femme mais
bon il fait vibrer tellement de fans
avec ses dribbles chaloupés on marche
sur la tête voilà le message que ça
envoie si vous êtes super talentueux
dans un domaine que la société valorise
on s'en fout que vous soyez quelqu'un de
bien être une bonne personne et moins
déterminant pour votre réussite sociale
que vos capacités artistiques et je
crois malheureusement que ce n'est pas
seulement la vieille société
institutionnelle boomer qui est coupable
de ce travail
on trouve partout des formes
d'admiration pour des compétences ou des
talents on fait une chaîne Youtube pour
donner des conseils de cuisine on fait
des street Twitter pour partager son
expertise scientifique on publie ses
dessins sur Instagram en espérant qu'il
plaise on montre des travaux de
rénovation qu'on a accompli pour faire
valoir nos capacités de bricoleur sur
TiK ToK on raconte sur Facebook le temps
qu'on passe à la salle de sport pour
témoigner de nos efforts et de notre
autodiscipline de manière générale on
célèbre les accomplissements des uns et
des autres on admire celles et ceux qui
réussissent ce qui nous semble difficile
ce que l'on serait incapable de réaliser
soi-même ça m'embête parce que je trouve
qu'il serait plus intéressant de
valoriser des comportements ordinaires
la façon dont une personne s'adresse à
une serveuse dans un café par exemple ça
me semble plus important que le savoir
jouer au piano
ou la manière dont on gère une rencontre
avec une personne précaire qui demande
de l'argent dans le métro dans la rue si
tu es indifférent ou pire méprisant tu
peux être le plus grand artiste du monde
tu auras pas un gramme de respect de ma
part j'ai mille fois plus d'estime pour
l'empathie et la solidarité que pour les
différents exploits qu'on nous vend
comme extraordinaire aussi bien ceux qui
font de longs voyages en solitaire comme
des aventuriers ceux qui sont une grande
artiste ou d'importance scientifiques
je suis en train de finir un monde
vulnérable de John pronto un truc que
j'ai trouvé important c'est qu'elle dit
que le soin n'a pas une place centrale
dans notre société ça s'explique
historiquement bien sûr parce que la
morale du soin fut associé aux femmes et
par conséquent contenu dans l'espace
privé du foyer la politique
l'organisation de la vie publique elle
devait être une histoire de rationalité
de gros cerveau
la société récompense davantage ce qui
cultive leur propre esprit que ceux qui
sont surtout préoccupés par le sort des
autres il est plus important d'être
intelligent que d'avoir le sens du soin
ça se traduit par exemple par le fait
que les métiers du soin sont
marginalisés ce sont souvent des femmes
et des non-blancs qui occupent ces
postes là et c'est mal payé évidemment
et là John Protot mentionne un cas
particulier les médecins c'est
clairement un métier de soins et on ne
peut pas dire que les médecins soient
marginalisés dans notre société au
contraire ce sont souvent des hommes
souvent blancs ils sont bien payés et
ils jouissent d'un vrai statut social
mais tantôt nous rappelle l'évidence en
réalité la valorisation symbolique dont
jouissent les médecins tient moins à
ceux qui dans leur métier relève du soin
que de ce qui relève de la compétence et
de la maîtrise technique la gloire que
tire les médecins tient davantage à leur
expertise supposée et de fait plus les
médecins sont connus et reconnus et plus
il consacre le temps à des activités
déconnecter des patients faire de la
recherche donner des conférences
participer à des Colocs etc
schématiquement plus le médecin est
scarifié moins il passe de temps à
soigner
ce qui est intéressant ici c'est que ça
nous donne un autre éclairage à notre
problème ce n'est pas simplement la
compétence que nous glorifions mais un
certain genre de compétences car le soin
suppose de véritables compétences savoir
écouter ça va entendre les besoins
savoir rassurer on pourrait allonger
cette liste en fait la société valorise
des compétences précises celle qui
relèvent d'une symbolique de la
puissance intellectuelle ou physique
celle qui conduisent à dire il est trop
fort on ne s'exclame pas il est trop
fort en gentillesse elle est trop forte
en honnêteté et je crois que c'est assez
révélateur parce que donc on admire pas
quelqu'un pour sa gentillesse ou son
honnêteté je crois que ça dit quelque
chose de notre culture et de ce qu'on
encourage
honnêtement moi j'ai l'impression que je
ne sais rien faire il n'y a pas si
longtemps j'ajoutais je ne sais même pas
conduire mais j'ai enfin passé le permis
donc c'est plus tout à fait vrai j'ai
écrit des livres des articles mais
est-ce que je sais écrire pas vraiment
c'est un certain point de la société
dans laquelle je vis qui s'exprime à
travers moi en aucun cas puis-je
prétendre avoir la maîtrise de mon
discours mon esprit est une éponge qui
absorbe des pensées environnantes et les
ressorts dans d'autres situations seul
un contexte favorable peut faire advenir
des phrases dans ma tête que je tape
ensuite sur mon clavier de manière
instinctive de la même manière si par
hasard mes vidéos vous intéressent c'est
grâce aux idées qui sont développées
mais ces idées s'imposent à moi comme un
film s'impose à notre regard je n'y peux
rien je ne suis pas l'auteur des idées
je ne suis pas capable de façonner une
pensée comme un menuisier fabrique une
table je suis pleinement passif je
reçois des mots dans la tête même si
l'idée est originale voir inédite je ne
considère pas que j'en suis le créateur
bref assez parlez de moi on s'en fout ce
que je veux dire vous l'avez compris
c'est qu'on a une forte tendance à
donner de la valeur au fait d'être
capable de quelque chose et ça peut
vouloir dire tout un tas de trucs ça
peut vouloir dire admirer la personne
qui est dotée de tel ou telle capacité
et comme on le sait l'admiration n'est
pas un sentiment sans risque cela
confère un statut particulier à la
personne admiré statue qui peut se
transformer en logique de domination ça
peut aussi vouloir dire mépriser les
individus qui ne sont pas capables de
telle ou telle chose
valoriser les compétences c'est aussi
considérer certaines aptitudes comme des
prérequis ainsi toute personne qui en
est dépourvu et déconsidérée voire même
parfois des humanisés c'est le danger
propre à ce qu'on nomme le valetisme une
tendance à percevoir les personnes
porteuses de handicap comme inférieures
en un certain sens au moins comme étant
diminué cela peut également nous
conduire à glorifie une compétence pour
elle-même de la glorifier indépendamment
du sens qu'elle a pour la communauté du
bien qu'elle fait à la Société de fait
la fonction de la compétence de la
société n'est visiblement pas une
préoccupation centrale typiquement la
capacité à écouter avec bienveillance
une personne qui souffre et dans notre
monde bien moins valorisé que la
capacité à savoir bien jouer au foot
on valorise la capacité à se distinguer
être original différent à se démarquer
bien plus que la discrétion la capacité
à se sacrifier à donner son temps etc
prenons le temps de demander pourquoi
valorisons-nous telle capacité je sens
que certains ont envie de me répondre et
c'est bizarre ton truc parce que
clairement c'est cool de savoir faire
des choses c'est cool que l'être humain
apprenne évolue progresse se dépasse
repousse les limites de ce qui peut
faire
et à ça je répondrai deux choses d'abord
j'aimerais bien qu'on questionne le
bien-fondé de ce présupposé est-ce qu'on
est véritablement sûr de ça et pourquoi
croisons cela pourquoi pense-t-on que la
vie humaine augmentait de techniques et
de savoir faut forcément davantage que
la vie préhistorique par exemple avant
même l'invention du feu pourquoi est-on
si certains que c'est mieux et qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ce mieux dans cette
intuition et puis on peut aussi faire
des comparaisons moins drastiques toutes
choses égales par ailleurs la vie en
2023 va-t-elle fondamentalement plus que
la vie en 1923 ou en 1823 je dis toute
chose égale par ailleurs parce que il
faut bien reconnaître que même si nous
vivons dans une société encore
extrêmement discriminante cela fut
souvent pire par le passé
donc quand bien même je considérais
qu'il est bon que l'être humain
progresse quel est le type de compétence
que l'être humain choisi de faire
progresser en priorité oui ce serait
super chouette que l'être humain
apprenne évolue progresse se dépasse et
repousse les limites de ce qu'il peut
faire en termes de justice sociale de
compassion de gentillesse et au lieu de
ça on célèbre plutôt des compétences
individualistes qui favorisent cette
espèce de grande compétition déterminant
la réussite sociale pourquoi ces
capacités là de manière générale
pourquoi aimons-nous fantasmé le héros
solitaire plutôt que la communauté
solidaire il faut croire que l’idéologie
dominante tend à valoriser l'individu
compétent et autonome plutôt que
l'entraide collective la compétition
plutôt que la coopération sans surprise
donc les compétences qui jouissent d'un
statut particulier sont souvent celles
des dominants donc des hommes des
bourgeois des blancs
dans notre monde une compétence
généralement associée aux gens masculins
comme safare bricoler un petit plus de
prestige que le savoir coudre par
exemple une compétence généralement
associée au genre féminin et au niveau
des classes sociales le fait de savoir
jouer du piano suppose une valeur
symbolique plus élevée que le fait de
savoir jouer aux jeux vidéo et si on
prend les 50 œuvres d'art les plus
chères du monde de seulement son peintre
par des noms blancs et encore toutes par
des hommes
[Musique]
pour conclure très rapidement vous
l'avez compris moi les gens qui savent
faire des trucs ça m'impressionne pas
des masses tant mieux pour eux et tant
mieux si leurs compétences font du bien
aux autres mais au-delà du fait que ça
n'impressionne pas je trouve qu'il y a
un truc pas net dans notre rapport aux
compétences ou aux performances dans
cette tendance avoir différemment un
individu à cause de ce qu'il est capable
de faire
c'est probablement révélateur d'un
fantasme de l'individu tout-puissant
auteur de ses actions et par extension
de sa propre valeur
au-delà de ça je me demande si on peut
dépasser fondamentalement la
valorisation de la puissance en général
est-il possible en tant que société de
considérer sérieusement que non ce n'est
pas mieux d'être plus fort plus
intelligent plus habile plus cultivé
plus malin plus drôle plus charismatique
j'imagine que cette idée paraîtra
bizarre à un certain nombre d'entre vous
mais peut-être qu'elle vous intriguera
quand même ou mieux encore qu'elle vous
fera réfléchir n'hésitez pas à partager
vos impressions en commentaire à bientôt
[Musique]